antonio guterres se reunió con volodymyr
ce lens quien quiere el representante de
naciones unidas aseguró que estaba
haciendo todo lo posible para permitir
la evacuación de más de 1000 civiles y
de cientos de combatientes en la planta
de azov tall and not going to no voy a
entrar en ningún comentario que pueda
socavar esa posibilidad de expositivo y
la enorme siderúrgica es el único
bastión que aún resiste en el puerto de
mariupol mayoritariamente en manos de
los rusos que aseguran que los civiles
pueden abandonar la planta pero los
combatientes tendrán que deponer las
armas selenski volvió a insistir en que
está preparado para hablar de la
situación en el puerto de azov y
denunció los continuos ataques a mumbai
vemos que a pesar de las palabras del
presidente ruso sobre el supuesto fin de
las acciones de combate en mariupol el
territorio de asof tal está siendo
bombardeado bárbaramente por el ejército
ruso antes del encuentro guterres visitó
las localidades de buche y boro de anca
allí recordó que son siempre los civiles
quienes pagan el precio más alto más
temprano selenski se reunió también con
su homólogo búlgaro kiril petkoff
acordaron apoyo para transportar la
producción agrícola de ucrania
principalmente granos a través del
puerto de varna en el mar negro y un
suministro de armas a ucrania petkoff
también visitó el ping donde aseguró que
está en disposición de cortar su
dependencia del gas ruso
nunca planeamos estar sin gas ruso hace
solo unos meses pero ahora tenemos
opciones y estamos comenzando a
desarrollar una estrategia alternativa
si somos capaces de hacerlo todos en
europa deberían poder hacerlo y devotos
web al otro lado del océano el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
sumo apoyo con una nueva solicitud de
fondos sánchez que acabo de firmar una
solicitud al congreso de asistencia
crítica en materia de seguridad
económica y humanitaria para ayudar a
ucrania seguir contrarrestando la
agresión de putin en total 33 mil
millones de dólares de los que 8 mil 500
millones irán destinados a ayuda
económica directa para que no colapse la
economía ucraniana